hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar diagnostic dilemma of mild
traumatic brain injury in the emergency
department i am antonina salcido of
labrutz and i i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by abbott
to learn more please visit coral
laboratory dot abbott
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting as many questions as you may
have during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation i'd like to
now welcome our speaker dr peter bibber
taller chair department for the trauma
surgery at technical university munich
germany dr bieber taller you may now
begin your presentation
antonia thank you very much for this
very friendly introduction
and ladies and gentlemen it's my
pleasure
to
illuminate the diagnostic dilemma of
minor traumatic brain injury in the
emergency department my name is peter b
batala i am the head of the trauma
department of the technical university
in munich
and by that i have to take care of the
trauma patients in our emergency
department so this is a little different
organized as compared to
the united states
so um what what is the
diagnostic dilemma of mild traumatic
brain injury
and
well these are my disclosures of course
and these are the aims of of our talk so
i will give you a short introduction
into the topic
and then we will flip through the actual
standard of diagnostic and then i will
give you an overview of
studies concerning biochemical markers
so far and a short outlook into the
future
so what's the matter with traumatic
brain injury
the point is that
it's not very clear defined
so
as you can see here
the the major definition is regarding to
the glasgow coma scale
so if you have a minor
traumatic brain injury it's defined as a
classical coma scale of 15 points and
it's the same as a concussion injury
then you have the miles between 13 and
15 points and the moderates between 9
and 12 points and severed alone 9 points
however
if you have less gcs points and then
your um
neurological impairment can do worse
so what's what's about this glass of
coma scale i i show you how it's
comprised
so it's it's a
a simple clinical scale and it comprises
a verbal response and an eye response
and a motoric response
in the verbal response you get five
points and i respond four points and
motoric response six points and all
together this is 15 points
and as you can see here
um
the neurological
function
is
something which has been
identified in time when imaging was not
widely distributed
so the glasgow common scale was
established before computer tomography
was widely distributed
it's a purely clinical risk
stratification tool
and it's not matching very nicely to
modern imaging preferences
this picture depicts the anatomical
basics so our brain is pretty nice
protected by the skull around of the
brain however
if you have any type of intracranial
pressure increase
it can't escape
so what is happening
and you can see here
the look from
from
from downsize what is happening is if
you have an increase of pressure the
brain is pressed against its natural
anatomic
frontiers
what does this mean as you can see here
and this means that the neurological
cells are not able to take their
function anymore they are pressed
against these
fronties
so this means if you have an
intracranial
pressure increase your brain is not able
to keep up its neurological function
why then are clinical symptoms so
unspecific
um this
is depicted in this slide
so you do not only have brain volume in
your
skull you also have fluids of course
material volume and venous volume
and liquor
and if you have an increase of
intracranial pressure by a bleeding for
example
first of all
all of those liquid
fluids are pressed out of the skull
and
this means that you have a period
of compensating intracranial pressure
until you
really have an increase of pressure on
neuron cells
so
this
[Music]
is depicted by this slide so if you have
an increase
of intracranial pressure given on the
y-axis
and the increase of intracranial volume
on the x-axis you can see that even with
a substantial increase in the initial
phase the interchangeable pressure is
not increasing
very much
however if you overrun the compensation
systems
then the neurological deterioration is
happening pretty fast
and this is the reason why the
neurological symptoms
given in the glasgow coma scale are so
unspecific because
they react
in a time point when the biological
compensation systems are completely
overrun
so as you can see here in this picture i
will show you that
the the phases before this overrun of
computation systems can be detected by
imaging or even earlier by biomarkers
so far imaging is the only rule out
technology of intracranial pathologies
as you can see here those
intrapreneurial pathologies are
named
like epidural or subdural or
supraochemical bleeding
all of them
lead to an increase of intracranial
pressure
however the gap between good and bad is
pretty small as you can see here
this patient has the typical clinical
appearance with raccoon eyes
but he has a glass sarcoma of 15
and he has a small epithelial hematoma
however
if you have a look on the next slide
you see that this patient is already
brain dead
so
the the frontier between good and bad is
pretty small
however
the majority of patients
fortunately do have a mild traumatic
brain injury
so this is the reason why in all
emergency departments of the world these
patients
do cause a substantial diagnostic
problem
because the symptoms are pretty
unspecific
and only three to fifteen percent of
those patients do have intracranial
complications
however
if you have an intracranial complication
even if you present with a glasgow coma
of 13 15 14 or 15 points in the
beginning the outcome
is
still as bad as if you have a initial
classical comer below 13 points
so this is our diagnostic problem
and this is the reason why it's so
difficult with traumatic brain injury
so the gold standard glasgow chroma
scale is very subjective
and the gap between good and bad outcome
is extremely narrow the numbers are high
and the majority of those patients do
have
mild traumatic brain injury
the symptoms are extremely unspecific
and so far
imaging is the only secure rule of
technology
i want to show you some data
how the indication for this imaging
technology was identified
and
this paper is one of the most famous one
by michelle heidel out of new orleans
and she identified several risk factors
um given in this slide
which drives the indication for a ct
scan after minor head injury
and if we have a look on the left hand
side
on the symptoms you see here short term
memory deficits
drug or alcohol intoxication well in
fact this means in our emergency
department we might scan
half of the emergency department during
friday night
then physical evidence of trauma above
the clavicles
age above 60 years
so you can see
these are risk factors which were
identified significantly with
bad intracranial
pathologies so it draw the indication
for ct
scan then it was analyzed how many
patients
do really have intracranial pathologies
and she demonstrated that it's something
around 6.3
so this means
if you apply these clinical rules
you do
almost 94
without finding intracranial pathologies
this is the canadian ct
head rule
also trying to identify clinical factors
which
might be able to
give a better indication for the ct scan
and you can see here the results
so these were the clinical risk factors
identified by the by the canadian group
so they they they thought that glasgow
were between 13 and 15 points loss of
consciousness amnesia and disorientation
might be a good indication
however they still have a high frequency
of negative scans of approximately 90
percent
and these are the ease practice
management guideline rules
[Music]
and you can see here
these are the clinical factors which
will draw the indication for initial
[Music]
ct scan in mild traumatic brain injury
patient
but if you have a thorough look on this
in practical medical use this might mean
that you scan almost everybody in the
emergency department after after head
trauma
because these are our typical patients
and this is the problem that the
majority of them
are intoxicated or even worse
they don't want to have a ct scan so and
what do we do with those patients
um so we might go for
sedation and intubation and they are not
sober
so in the clinical setting this is
really a pretty problematic situation
and every emergency physician in the
world knows this
so the indication for the for the ct
scan
of course if you have a glasgow coma
below 13 points there's no question then
you always go for a scan
if you are between 13 and 15 points the
indication is risk depending if you have
symptoms such as amnesia vomiting pain
pleasure etc
okay now you're experts and we try to
get for a more interactive quiz
uh
let's go through this
this patient female 53 years old she has
an accident with another bicyclist
glasgow cuomo is 15 points
and if you ask her
have you been unconsciousness she says i
don't know
no vomiting no nausea
so um
what does this mean if she says i don't
know if it was unconsciousness well this
means
most probably she was
who wants to have a ct scan
well i give you a little bit more
information for this
so this is the pole who wants to have a
ct scan
and this was her bicycle helm and i have
a nice gathering of cracked bicycle helm
so i just can recommend you if you drive
bicycle use a helmet and you can see
here how the helmet has been cracked
and this is her scans he has a very
small subterroral hematoma but requires
no neurosurgical performance so in this
case
it was
correct
then our next patient
typical
emergency department patient during the
weekend
male 53
fall from a bar stool
initially no motion he has a big
hematoma he opened his eyes on demand
he's heavily intoxicated and says very
bad words to the stuff so who wants to
have a ct scan in this patient
uh i think everybody wants to have a ct
scan in this patient but the problem is
the patient does not want to have a ct
scan so what do we do now
go do we go for sedation intubation
think about the aspiration risk and so
forth
so in this situation put this patient as
a scanner is pretty high risk
however
i think everybody of us is agreeing that
probably it would be a good idea so this
is the poll
you can answer yes or no
and this is his scan and as you can see
here he has a uh
bleeding temporal and requires
neurosurgical
surgery
so another patient this guy 85 year old
he stumbled over his persian carpet at
home
has a laceration no medication
so he's above 85 according to the rules
who wants to have a ct scan
you can give the poll here who wants to
have the ct scan
yes here's the scan but he has no
intracranial pathology
so let me take this together
tbi diagnosis is pretty subjective
if you do this to clinical symptoms it's
extremely subjective
so taken together
minor tbi patients with a glass go of 13
to 15 points is one of the central
diagnostic problems in emergency
departments all over the world
management only by clinical factors is
extremely insufficient and this is
inducing a high frequency of unnecessary
ct scans
of course radiation and costs
moreover
this is causing a substantial logistic
problem to the stuff by scanning all of
those 13 to 15 points patient
so
minor traumatic brain injury has a risk
stratification problem
so our scientific efforts focused on an
identification identification of an
additional
quantitative examiner independent factor
to help improve this risk stratification
for minor traumatic brain injury
patients
this is what we were trying to solve
scientifically so we thought that
probably we might be able to find more
sensitive and quantitative parameter
which might
allow identification of patients with
intracranial pathologies even before
their clinical symptoms start to
deteriorate
so these were the key hurdles
will we have an accurate indication of
of traumatic brain injury or concussion
and
will we be able to have this within
those given time periods for different
patient collectives
and will we have an adequate comparison
to baseline
levels now i will demonstrate you some
studies
so as you can see here these biomarkers
are currently under investigation
so we have the s100 the uchl1 and the g5
all the others are
more experimental investigated on
so what's the s100 it's an astrocyte
protein
and the theory is that if you have a
crack on your head the blood-brain
barrier is opening very shortly and then
this protein is washed out to the
systemic circulation where it can be
measured
there were some early studies in the
2000 years uh where uh from the
neurosurgeons um
s100 was measured on patients and they
were very promising however
those numbers were far too low to change
clinical decision rules of course
so we planned our study
we wanted to identify a safe and
effective cut-off level to rule out
intracranial lesions and our statistical
targets were sensitivity above 99
because of course
uh what we
what we really do not wanted to have is
a patient which we over see any kind of
intracranial pathology
this was the planning it was a
multicentric prospective study and the
study collective contained healthy
volunteers
and then our study group a
minor head injured group with a glass of
coma of 13 to 15 points and risk factors
and a positive control group with
glasgow patients below 13 points
all patients receive the gold standard
scan in the emergency department and as
a biomarker and the s100 was measured on
the washing machine
these are the numbers so first of all we
identified
540 healthy volunteers
to get a good cut-off value
and then we
enrolled more than 1 300 patients with a
glasgow coma of 13 to 15 points
and 93 patients in the positive control
group oh sorry and 93 of those patients
had a positive ct scan
and 1216 are negative ct scan
and in the positive control group we had
55
patients with a glass of coma below 13
points
this is our publication
out of this study
and here you can see the graph
first of all on the top you see the
control collective where we identified
the cup of level and we identified a
cutoff level of 0.1 micrograms per liter
and if we apply this to the study
collective we found that one third of
the ct negative patients were below this
cutoff
and
almost all patients with a positive ct
scan were above the cut-off level
this is the roc curve of this and as you
can see
the parameter is able to distinguish
pretty nicely between
between
intracranial
bleeding or not
however you might ask yourself what
about the patients
which do have an elevated s100 level but
a negative ct scan
well the problem is that although the ct
scan is the gold standard in the
emergency department the detection level
and the technique which is done there
routinely is that you see small spots
not if they are smaller than two
millimeters so what we did is we did a
subgroup analysis and put those patients
after an elevated s100 and a negative ct
scan additionally to the mri scanner and
what we saw is
that in those in this group 30
had significant mri signs of injury so
our specificity problem of the of the
parameter is not a real specificity
problem it's a problem of the gold
standard
then i want to introduce you to this
study so this was a prospective
multi-center study where
um g-fab concentrations were analyzed in
in
mri
and as you can see here
it was analyzed if
in patients with the classical coma of
13 to 15 points
and a positive or negative ct scan
alterations in an additional mri scan
was seen
and what you can see here is that in a
substantial
percentage
of patient with a negative ct scan
a secondary positive mri scan was
achieved
so our specificity shoulder as i call it
here
is pretty nicely explained by the gold
standard
problem
so the
group around you
concluded that biomarkers are probably
more sensitive than a ct
but the gold standard is the problem of
all those studies
and this is what i want to show you with
this graph which i have shown before
so
if those patients do have intracranial
bleeding
and they
they demonstrate
symptoms then the compensating
systems are already overrun
before that you might be able to
identify those patients using imaging
but even before that you might be able
to identify those patients using
biomarkers
then we were asked what about
intoxication because so many patients
are intoxicated as they have
intracranial if they have
minor traumatic brain injury so what we
did is we did a study on intoxicated
patients
and analyzed if there was an influence
of alcohol on the s100
and as you can see here this is the
blood alcohol level in our study groups
on the left hand side you see the
patient
with a with an
average alcohol of 1.8
and you see the study group of our
non-traumatized
mild intoxication patients and the heavy
intoxication patients who wanted to
withdraw from alcohol
and this is the result of the s100
measurement in the these collectives as
you can see here the only factor
which leads to an increase of s100 was
the fact of a positive ct scan
all other
all other groups did not have a
significant increase of s100
this means that alcohol has not an
influence in this respective
so um i want to show you um if our data
was uh reproduced by other centers this
is always important in the scientific
community and as you can see here the
norwegian group around miller and trump
they demonstrated almost similar results
with a threshold of 0.13
of the s100 on their collective
and another center in japan did almost
the same
and they also demonstrated very nice
very nice results which
showed that our results were reproduced
in other centers
so
these results led to implementation of
the measurement of biomarkers in the
clinical routine so this was the
publication of the american college of
emergency physicians of 2008
and as you can see here there's a
recommendation level c recommendation
in mild traumatic brain injury patient
without significant extracranial
injuries
and the s100
lower than 0.1
you might be able to
postpone a ct scan however in these days
this factor was not
approved in the united states
but the measurement of biomarkers also
was able to were taken into the
scandinavian guidelines as you can see
here
so
this measurement is already partially
used in clinical routine
so now i want to
demonstrate you some other markers who
were investigated on you can see here
those names
for example the top 14 this was an
analysis on hockey players however you
see that there is not a real good
significant significant increase
and on the right hand side also i know
that the
neurospecific amylase is in the
guidelines of
of neurological
intensive care patients
in the
minor traumatic brain injury
setting it obviously has not such a
significant
impact
so these are two markers which are more
promising than the g-fab and uchl-1 on
this picture depicts where they are
coming from
and i i received these slides
from from the us army thank you
for this because they started the
studies very early as you can see here
so they did a feasibility study on those
markers and i will
be able to share the contents with you
as you can see here
um the uchl1 and the g-feb were
significantly increased
in traumatic brain injured patients
uh and this is the roc curve regarding
those markers as you can see there is a
significant discrimination
of intracranial pathologies by these
markers
so starting from this we went to the
alert tbi study and we wanted to analyze
if the uchl1 and gfab were able to
to detect patients suffering from
intracranial pathologies after traumatic
brain injury
so what we did we planned this sample
and again
we wanted to have a very high
test sensitivity
this is the publication of this
study
done by
a multi-center multinational group
and i can show you all the centers so
most of them were in the united states
but one in hungary and several in
germany
so this was the planning of the study
and
the planning was that we wanted to
identify
if
g-fab and uchf1 were able to identify
those patients
which were at risk after traumatic brain
injury
and uh this were the primary objective
so as you can see here we enrolled
patients with a glasgow chrome of 13 to
15 points
to um obtain our study goals
this were the study profile as you can
see here this were the tree of the
patients where they were enrolled
and this were the findings so um
1920 patients were evaluable with a
glass of chrome of 14 to 15 points
from these
um
5.9
had detected intracranial injuries
and 0.5
required a neurosurgical intervention
so um in in this collective the test
performance was pretty good so the
sensitivity was 97.3
and the negative predictive value was
99.5
so you can see here
that
the specificity and the sensitivity was
extremely good
in this study
moreover we analyzed
when those patients came to our
emergency department and as you can see
here
um most of them came
in between the first four hours so this
was the critical time point where we
wanted to identify those patients
um
after traumatic brain injury
so the conclusions um
the the
g-fab and uc-hl1
was able to identify patients
and rule out
more than one third of patients with a
negative ct scan
and all neurosurgical lesions were
identified by the test
so from this
future research was um suggested so um
[Music]
the those markers were
um asked if they could be
analyzed on poc platforms
and a clinical rule and test
should be developed
these were the the investigators of this
study
and
then i want to show you
a very nice review which was recently
published
about the uc hl1 the gfab
as you can see here
this is the time point of
the release of those markers and as you
can see
not all markers are released at
the similar time point so
it's important to know when the
traumatic event happened so you know
how in which phase of your elevation
curve
your marker will be
so this is a most recent review
concerning
biomarkers and you can see here the
study demo diagram
and you can see here the distribution of
gfab and uchl1 and subjects
with glasgow chrome of 13 to 15 points
so
you can see again that those markers do
have a very nice performance
detecting intracranial pathologies
and the characteristics of the false
negative subject
you can see here
all of those do not require
neurosurgical intervention
so let me take it together
i showed you why
minor traumatic brain injury is a real
diagnostic dilemma and the clinical risk
factors are extremely subjective
so far imaging is the only rule out
technology in those patients but
biomarkers are extremely promising
so far the s100 is the best
characterized but the uchf1 and the gfab
[Music]
demonstrated that they even get better
results i personally think the the
solution will be a panel
and i want to thank you for your
attention and i'm open for questions
thank you
thank you dr beverteller for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and we'll answer
as many of your questions as we have
time for
now let's get started
our first question
is what are the challenges in the
utilization of the cdrs during the
assessment of patients in the ed
well the problem is what i wanted to
demonstrate you with my clinical cases
is that the clinical decision rules
are
are pretty subjective
so if you um calculate a glass glacoma
scale
from those patients
um
the
the measurement of this classical coma
scale
has a problem that it's depending very
much from the experience of the
physician
and from the intoxication situation
and probably from other factors
but not so much from intracranial
pathologies
this
means that if you use
the clinical risk factors as an
indication for the ct scan
the problem is that you will have a very
high number of negative ct scans
great thank you for that answer
another question we have what do you see
as the major hurdle for potential
widespread implementation of tbi
biomarkers
i think
[Music]
the the biggest problem will be the fact
that
physicians are used to positive testing
strategies so
if you have a marker and it's above a
threshold level then this generally is
identified as pathologic
and
in this
setting of the biomarkers of
intracranial pathologies and it's in a
rule out parameter
which means that
if you have a patient
with a negative biomarker test then you
can be sure that there is no
intracranial pathologies
in all other patients with a potential
positive biomarker test you might
manage like you managed those patients
before
so if you do that
you might be able to reduce the number
of unnecessary ct scans about
at least one third
thank you um and our next question what
were the challenges or lack of full
implementation of s100b
well the same i just mentioned the
problem was that was
it was um
it was widely distributed to emergency
physicians and
um
they
they used it probably
uh very widely and
they found
as i showed you that the two thirds
are above the threshold level
so
they thought well this parameter is not
discriminating very well
however
i personally think
it was a
teaching problem of implementation of
the parameter
because
if you teach the emergency physicians
that it's a rule out parameter and it
helps to improve the indication for the
ct scan
this
will
help the emergency physician a lot
great and we have time for about one
more question
so our last question will implementation
of these new technologies have an impact
on emergency physicians and patients
length of stay in the ed
absolutely i'm absolutely convinced
that um
if you measure those biomarkers
and it's negative
then you can
treat this patient
like you did before you probably stitch
his round and give him a
tightened vaccination and after this he
can go and he can be sure that there is
no risk of intracranial pathology
and if he
falls again on his head during this
night
you have a quantitative parameter which
very clearly demonstrates that when he
was in your hands there was no risk
perfect thank you thank you dr
rivertaller do you have any final
comments for our audience
thank you for listening and
i'm looking forward for all of those new
biomarkers for the diagnostic of minor
traumatic brain injury
great thank you again for your time
today and your important research
we'd also like to thank lab roots and
our sponsor abbott for underwriting
today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions questions we
did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand
libraries will alert you via email when
it's available for replay and we
encourage you to share that email with
any colleagues or friends who may have
missed today's live event
thank you until next time goodbye